Countries are getting more corrupt!
But corruption doesn't always look the same.
Let's unpack!
Imagine a cute little town with a mayor,
a court, police,
businesses etc.
First, we need to ask – who is corrupt?
There’s public corruption.
That would be a public official taking a bribe –
like a policeman or a judge.
And then political corruption –
like the mayor of our little town.
Often the ones paying the bribes are private companies,
like the owner of our local factory
bribing the mayor to not have to abide by the environmental laws.
Secondly, what kind of transaction is this?
It could either be a bribe –
a judge getting cash for not sending you to prison
or extortion –
which can involve threats and abuse of power –
like the mayor telling a journalist:
"If you print this article,
I will ruin your newspaper."
It could also be nepotism –
like the mayor appointing his brother to be the new judge.
Thirdly, how big and how often?
Here we have petty bribery –
that's the policeman with the ticket again –
minor corruption
but it's being repeated.
And grand corruption –
lots of money –
less repetition –
like the mayor taking a large donation from a company
so that they get to build the new town hall.
Lastly, how corrupt is our town really?
Is it just a few individuals taking bribes?
Or is it systemic –
a whole institution or even the whole government are corrupt.
So, why do we define corruption at all?
NGOs like Transparency International try to fight corruption globally.
It’s new report shows corruption is on the rise.
And it changes and adapts to new laws.
They say to fight it
we need to know what it looks like.
Do you know how corrupt your country is?